Muller incorporated as a manufacturer
and retailer of steel building products
we were talking about a way that we can
connect the construction professional
with Muller in a much more seamless way
that would increase the customer
satisfaction and we couldn't afford to
to really mess it up and so that's why
we brought in the IBM garage to assist
us with this
there wasn't one game changer that we
took away from the IBM cloud garage
there were actually three the first
thing from the IBM garage was the
application of design thinking bringing
the customer in looking at the system
holistically and in really determining
what is the best foot forward we drilled
down to their biggest pain point and
they would come to me ler and then the
salesperson would work up a price quote
it would go back to the construction
professional who then turn it back over
to his customer now you re scoping that
and the cycle starts all over again the
second thing was the MVP so the
technology solution that we built was
how about we shift that to the
construction professional allow him to
work that out so he has the satisfaction
of his own self service and the MVP was
a new term to us the idea of getting the
highest amount of value at the lowest
cost in the shortest amount of time and
we're applying this now in other
processes not just for technology and
that and then finally the impact of
design the fact that that design is
woven in the voice of the customer can
be seen in every aspect of a tool that
we built and we can onboard a customer
in about 90 seconds this was just a
different way of approaching the
development of a software product so
successful was this that my CEO said it
this is the type of problem-solving
approach I I want the company to take